it really boils down to empathy you know
there's this this phrase that's thrown
around so often that people fear change
no they don't people fear Sudden Change
yeah and you have to remember you know
many of the people in your organization
you know many of them have been doing
the job the way they've always been
doing it for five years ten years 15
years 20 years and now we're going to
say okay it's going to be a little
different the fear is not from the
change the fear is from the
unfamiliarity the fear is that I know
how to do that really really well and I
fear that I don't know how to do that
and I will feel insecure I'll be off my
game I'll lose my credibility
um and you just have to put yourself in
their shoes the the fear is being
humiliated you know I don't understand
the jargon it's all new you know it's a
whole host of things so empathy is King
empathy is King and not assuming that
everybody knows and people come along
with new directions at different Paces
we can't assume it's like getting into
shape you know everybody goes to the gym
but some people get into shape quicker
than others there's no rule it's just
how it works
um and it's the same here some people
come along lickety-split and some people
are just a little slower the ones that
are
um potentially destructive are the ones
that are so afraid that they actually
put up barriers and become obstreperous
they actually they actually resist the
change to the point where they're
clinging onto the past so desperately
that they they may accidentally sabotage
themselves
um and those are the ones that we have
to have difficult conversations with sit
down and say I need to have a difficult
conversation with you I I I get a sense
that you're struggling because
everything we're trying to do all you do
is say no and I understand it's
difficult but we got to talk about this
because the company is going in this
direction and I want you to be a part of
this but I am patient and to have that
conversation privately
with empathy that someone can come clean
and say I'm I'm scared because then you
can hold their hand
you know uh so I think empathy is
actually the the court the core to
helping people manage change